we need a president who will lower our
taxes and not raise our taxes we need a
president like Donald Trump we need a
president who understands the American
people are sick and
tired of being sick and
tired we
need we need a president our foreign
adversaries are afraid of love and our
allies respect we
need first time I met Tim Scott I I was
introduced to him and told that had
Senator Scott not become a politician he
would have been a preacher and I I I
couldn't quite tell he's a he's a really
wholesome sweet guy and you know he
appears not to have any vices whatsoever
so that's kind of what I thought was
meant by that but now I hear him speak I
say oh I see it you know we need Donald
Trump